first of all congratulations on season
five I binged the first Eight Episodes
yesterday ahead of this interview and it
is probably the best season yet so
congratulations on that that's great now
I know as a viewer the show is extremely
emotionally exhausting what is it like
for you and do you have to find ways to
kind of separate yourself from what's
happening in the series you know I wish
that I had like a really
um like poignant answer for that but I
just have so much fun at work I have so
much fun I just I love my co-workers I
love the people I work with
our whole crew is like the best crew on
the planet
um
we just have great times so it's really
not like the emotional preparation for
certain things yes is very heavy but
it's also something that I
I really love to do so it feels it
doesn't really feel
that heavy
I feel like I should say like it is
really but it's not like I love this
character so much I love this show so
much I love these people
it's just a
I don't know
well for the season are there any really
rewarding parts of Janine's story that
really stood out to you well yeah I mean
um Janine kind of steps into some June
energy this season
and that was I mean that's so rewarding
to kind of
see the way that her friend has so
impacted her
um and now that June is gone from Gilead
and Janine is there
um
Janine kind of steps up in a way that
um she
she was happy to never do while Jude was
there but realizing that there there is
an absence there is a there's a missing
piece and someone needs to fill that
role
um
I don't think you can get through Gilead
at all without a June so I think Janine
recognizes that she needed to be these
new girls she needed to be there June
a version of You Yes um and she has a
bond for a little bit there with Esther
can you talk a little bit about that
kind of not I don't know if it's exactly
a mentorship but that connection that
they have because they've been through
so much together already yeah I think
that um
I mean first of all I love McKenna I
love that girl
she's just so much fun to work with and
she's so oh my God what a prolific
teenager she is it's like wacko
um but
yeah I mean
I think part of it is the fact that like
Janine
I think is it's necessary for her to
Mentor
um
kind of in the way and to guide in the
way that she was Guided by June but I
also think that she recognizes
um
that this girl is
how how can I keep her alive and I can't
let her I can't allow her to make the
same mistakes that I made
because she knows what to expect and
she's not gonna not on Janine's
Not underneath Janine's watchful eye
literally will she allow someone else to
go through what she's gone through and
to make the mistakes that she's made
um
and uh
one of them being Warren
um
I think that she's just
she's been through so much
and she can't watch it happen to someone
else
yeah and also there's the motherhood
element that she's like look at this
little baby bird that I must nurture
I did want to talk about the war and
stuff with spoilers I'm going to hold
these until we get a little bit later
into the season uh but what happens with
Warren is adjust dessert for Janine as
much as it is for Esther so what is
going through Janine's head when she
sees that there are consequences to the
actions of the men in Gilead I think
that that makes her um
I don't know I feel like there's a
little bit of power for her there in
knowing that
just in that feeling of like well at
least they're not getting totally away
with it because they're not totally
getting away with it
um
I think there it's such mixed emotions I
think that Janine truly did love Warren
and feel like they had a
special connection
um
and she really believed what he was
telling her and I think that there's
a very complicated feelings around that
like when we're all looking at him at
the wall it was just like
I'm not sure excuse me I'm not sure what
I'm meant to feel right now
um for Janine I think it's just like
yeah but to see a consequence a
consequence of their actions is is very
powerful for her I think
I kind of excuses her of kind of using
her to see her child at you know the
putnam's place
how does that resonate with finnine does
she did she consciously choose to kind
of maneuver herself in so she does get
to see her daughter again or is it more
of just like it just happened that way
I think that Janine is always Conjuring
a plan to go and see her daughter I
think it's just like built into her so I
don't think that she sees it as
manipulation or as in um like using
Esther I think that she's just like
it's always at the Forefront of her mind
can I see my daughter will I be able to
see my daughter
um
and so everything else is kind of
secondary
um
but I think that she also in a very real
way she knows this household she knows
this man she knows this wife
um she knows I think
that at the very least
it is a safe ish household
um
like it's a good I mean they're
incredibly wealthy like that you know
the Silver Lining things of like
well yeah you get raped monthly but you
know
you have a really nice room you know
like the little things that only Janine
would be like but yeah like the Silver
Lining things that of course but if
that's how you survive because that's
how she survived is is finding something
good to hold on to and then a fun
question off of that kind of grim
reminder of this world that they're
living in when I like do character work
I always come up with songs and
playlists and stuff like that so I'm so
curious if like Janine has an Anthem or
something you listen to to get into her
headspace before going on set
let me look at my Spotify playlist I
knew you would have one I really do I do
that for like every character I play
usually has kind of like a I don't know
how else to describe like a trigger song
um
for Janine it is all I have to do is
dream by the Everly Brothers
um
that's one of her that's one
um
uh
This Bitter Earth by Dinah Washington
um I only want to be with you by Dusty
Springfield
um
You've Got a Friend by James Taylor
yeah those are some of them those are
great
well thank you so much that's the number
one that's the that's a good one that's
a good track excellent well thank you so
much I really appreciate it you taking
the time this early in the morning to uh
chat with collider my pleasure